our Kelly's live-in girlfriend who
defended him amid sexual misconduct
allegations is now apparently calling
him a monster and is saying she is also
a victim turned survivor on the
crowdfunding website patreon a woman
claiming to be Joycelyn savage describes
the singer as controlling and abusive
she also says Kelly got her pregnant
twice and just a warning some of what
she has to say is quite disturbing do
both of you all believe you're in love
with him yes absolutely of course this
was Joycelyn savage in March when Gayle
sat down with her and our Kelly's other
live-in girlfriend Ezreal Clary to speak
about their relationship with the 52
year old singer he's our full support
and we his full support and all we need
is each other but now on the website
patreon
someone claiming to be Savage says Kelly
is abusive and forced her to call him
master or daddy according to the post
when she didn't kelly grabbed her and
choked her until she blacked out CBS
News has not been able to independently
verify its savage making the posts
savage now 24 says she met Kelly when
she was 19 years old and pursuing a
music career for years she publicly
defended him including in this interview
with TMZ and I in a happy place with my
life and I'm not being brainwashed or
anything like that savage now allegedly
claims she was told what to say in that
video and in others she said a member of
Kelly staff starved her for days at a
time until she learned her scripted
lines word-for-word she also claimed
Kelly got her pregnant twice and she got
an abortion both times she wrote it's
scary having your first child and
aborting them because of some monster
that kept me as a prisoner
that's stupid use your common sense
Kelly broadly denied allegations of
abusing women and his interview with
Gale how stupid would it be for me to
with my crazy pass of what I've been
through
oh right now I just think I need to be a
monster and hold girls against they will
chain them up in my basement
and don't let them eat the new
accusations come as Kelly is in jail
awaiting trial he faces federal and
state sex crimes charges which include
child pornography and allegations he
recruited underaged girls and women to
have sex with him
Jocelyn if you do hear my message please
know that your mother loves you dearly
savages family has begged her for
several years to leave Kelly this is
what her father told Gayle in March a
father love will never change for his
daughter what do you all have to say to
our Kelly really really he need to rot
in jail
Gerald Griggs is the savage family
attorney and says they are concerned by
the apparent new posts and they are
ready to do whatever it takes to get her
in a safe comfortable environment where
she can reconnect with her family in a
statement are Kelly's attorney Stephen
greenberg said it was not until the
money ran out that savage decided
anything was wrong
Greenberg condemned her for seeking
money he says to exploit her loving
relationship with Kelly Kelly has
pleaded not guilty to all charges and is
expected to go to trial in the spring
and that being that federal case first
but it's gonna be interesting to see if
Azreal Cleary comes out with her version
of what happened or what she says
happened and if the slen savage will
cooperate with authorities if she has
any information that will you know build
their cases I mean they're already
pretty strong but and we know you'll be
on it you've been honest yeah you know
we have been on top of it so this is a
very interesting development as we say
though we're still not we haven't
confirmed that was actually correct